I recently got a GI BAP and Bicotoxin test results, a GI BAP, no H-Cyllory issues.
That's good.
Opportunistic bacterium balances.
Yes.
Staff orius,
streptococcus,
low levels of secretory,
IGA,
and occult blood.
So this is inflammation in the gut,
and you have some bacteria in the gut.
So I have to look at your protocol that I have you on.
First of all,
I'd probably be thinking of,
of,
andrographis,
and gerberine,
for these,
what I would do,
the occult blood has to do this person has colon cancer,
so that's to be expected.
But I would think that those are the kind of things I would think of with this.
The Bicotox test shows,
occultoxin,
A,
high,
and,
but not showing any,
no mold in your house.
So the Bicotox test doesn't test for mold in your house,
so I'm assuming you're saying,
that you don't notice any mold in your house,
you really,
you'd want to get some mold plates to see if you have mold in your house.
If your occultoxin test is high,
so where you get occultoxin, A,
that means you were exposed to a mold that produces that,
that Bicotoxin.
Now that mold that produces that Bicotoxin is commonly found in some foods,
When you have high levels of okra toxin A, that means you were exposed to a mold that produces that that mycotoxin.
Now that mold that produces that mycotoxin is commonly found in some foods that is very commonly found in mold that would be in buildings and in your home and things like that.
So it is probably the most common bichotoxin to be elevated because we're often exposed to mold in homes and buildings in schools.
I mean, everybody's bedded as, you know, especially schools, I could still smell the mold in my memory of my school when I was in grade school.
Yeah, in my case, there's no mold in my home that I'm aware of, but there's a meditation hall in the field house where I take kids to play that is loaded with mold and I had to actually leave that place and couldn't go there and I haven't gone back for, you know, probably over a month now.
OK, so when you have elevated okra toxins, that end of toxins of that mold production, so you still have to detoxify those.
So those are poisons that that mold produced that are in your body still.
So the reason why you get your home tested and get your, you know, you can smell them and you can, you kind of got a pretty good idea.
You have to do that investigation of, OK, where did I get this, because I don't want current exposure, because if you're going to detoxify that and I like that, that's what I like about our clear talks product.
If you're going to detoxify that and you have current exposure, but, you know, you're never going to really detoxify the toxins that mold produces are poisonous to everyone.
And they can really make us ill and okra talks a is a cancer causing agent.
So pulling that out of your body, but also, you know, making sure that you don't have hidden current exposure.
So if you, like you said, and you went to these certain places and you could smell molds, you had to exit those areas, do not go there again.
And maybe inform, you know, higher powers that they should get that clean up because other people are getting sick too. It's not going to be just you.
So these are very dangerous things.
And not just as just because they're our, our carcinogens, but they can make, they can cause inflammation in the brain, they can cause all sorts of really serious problems.
So mold is a serious issue that needs to be dealt with.
Detoxied it is the thing. So you're detoxing. These are poisons. This isn't the mold. This isn't mold in your system now.
It's the toxins that the mold produces. That's in your system. And you detox it with key layers. So, and binders. So really any binders and any key layers can really help pull these things out.
And I did look at your, your phone call, but you might already be on some of those things. So, I'll look at your phone call tomorrow and email you. I think there's anything else ready to change. Thank you.